wenn ich im wasser bin bin ich glaube
wenn ich beispielsweise wieder auf das
grüne hier bin ich dann grün wenn ich
mich vor einem baum stelle werde ich so
ein bisschen bräunlicher und mit viel
fantasie kann man mich gar nicht mehr
erkennen
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
hier zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft commands heute am freitag ja
sie kommen heute mal pünktlich ich hab
mir wieder 3,1 rausgesucht die ganz nah
ich habe auch diesmal drei größere
command und damit die folge ein bisschen
länger gebe mich freuen wenn ihr bis zum
ende dran bleiben würde das video
bewerten würde wenn ihr alles macht was
irgendwie cool ist schon wieder und dann
würde ich sagen fangen wir auch
eigentlich schon an direkt mit dem
ersten command format unterstrich block
dann bekomme ich ja schon ersten command
block neben mir einen hebel setzte den
dort neben und füge dort diesem command
ein und zwar das der magic wand command
von lego ska und zwar bekommt man
dadurch so unfassbar tolle zauberstäbe
und alles möglich und ihr seht schon da
oben ist die maschine jetzt fertig und
man denkt sich erstmal was ist denn
jetzt passiert allerdings ist das wieder
so ein command wo man selber so ein
bisschen was machen muss das heißt ich
erstmal in den amboss und ich hole mir
vier verschiedene place rottweil damit
die muss ich jetzt unterschiedlich
benennen damit ich durch das quasi mal
zeigen kann was überhaupt dieser
kommentar hinzufügen ich hab mir das
ganze hier schon perfekt aufgeschrieben
auf drei verschiedene von diesem posten
dingern weil die command heute wieder
sehr umfangreich sind und wenn ich jetzt
hier beispielsweise beim slam oder und
ich habe keine ahnung wie genau das
ausgesprochen wird eingeben und hier
dieses team hinnehmen
habe ich einen moslem wenn ich das jetzt
wieder hier rein packe und ich gebe wo
wohnt oder man keine ahnung spielt hier
ein dann habe ich diesen zauberstab
wenn ich das ganze eingeben und ich gebe
rund bindestrich dessauerin dann bekomme
ich den hier und wenn ich jetzt den hier
nochmal rein legen und diese lohn route
in fire strike umbenennen dann bekomme
ich noch einen anderen zauberstab und
jetzt manchmal eben kurze alles auf
times at night und hole mir ein paar
zombies noch leben mit anstand war die
denn da mal die zombies ok normalerweise
habe ich jetzt die zombies gesponnen und
jetzt habe ich hier diese vier
verschiedenen zauberstäben und kann
jetzt eigentlich mit dem once lemm
wenn ich den den drop des achters
funktioniert hat von 10 gefunden hat
nicht geklappt also ich hab jetzt gar
dieses trocken gedrückt sie hat
wahrscheinlich gesehen die zombies sind
hoch geflogen und mein zauberstab ist
dementsprechend jetzt auch weg also der
effekt wenn ich den ich weise den fire
strike x nehmen da unten liegt dann kann
die eigentlich anstellen aber das hatte
gerade nicht geklappt ich weiß nicht ob
ich rechtsklick auf die drauf machen
muss oder oder kuh drücken muss aber
irgendwie hat das geklappt wenn ich die
teilnehmer und co drücke seht ihr schon
hier dann fangen sie an zu brennen so
ganz komisch und ich bin quasi von
seiner des aura umgeben und die greift
dann auch diese promis ja ich muss
bleibt man darauf achten dass ich sterbe
und dann habe ich noch den rang schielt
deshalb herzen der komplett für mich
gerade ganz gut
und zwar wenn die dann an mir dran sind
nicht einfach mal cool drücke dann
bekomme ich so blöd blick ziemlich rum
und die können mich ruhig angreifen und
ihr seht schon tut mir nicht weh mein
leben gerät generiert sich auch
eigentlich allerdings naja ich habe
gerade ein bisschen hunger deswegen
regeneriert sich das nicht so krass und
da bekomme ich auf jeden fall keinen
schaden also das ist quasi wie sonnen
schild vor diese chance und ich kann ihn
dann angreifen und man stellt das werk
das ist auf jeden fall command nummer
eins werden vier zauberstäbe hinzugefügt
ich hatte gerade schon angst dass dieser
feier strecke funktioniert er hat auch
nicht funktioniert ich weiß nicht warum
ach ich weiß warum ich hab nicht warnt
davor geschrieben von den zombies vorne
sind zombies larsson skelett ich muss
glaube ich einfach mal als ins wasser
springen
also das ist command nummer eins fügte
diese zauberstäbe hinzu die alle eine
bestimmte fähigkeit haben der nächste
command ist von mister gay parade als
basis der utilities chromatik denn hier
erstmal ein drücke hier schön auf dem
schalter und fitschen das board sich
wieder eine schöne maschine mister
charakter mäßig allerdings wie wir die
mieter kennen ist das keine normale
maschine wo ich irgendwie auf einem
schild klick und ich bekomme meine items
da sehen wir wieder kein schild dran
sondern ich muss mir den ganzen shit
selber zusammen suchen das heißt ich
mache jetzt erst mal kurz den cut und
hole mir die ganzen items sich dafür
brauche und zwar hab ich mir jetzt hier
schon die ganzen sachen ins inventar gut
und zwar wenn ich jetzt einen stock
dorthin schweizer und ein prisma riehen
kristall seht ihr schon bekomme ich
einen mob repellent wenn ich ein eisen
loch in einen amboss hinschmeißen seht
es schon bekomme ich ein ende einer
eisbox wenn ich jetzt eine eisen
falschen schwarzpulver dorthin schmeiße
bekomme ich ein smog detektor und wenn
ich eine stein stufe und einen
komparatoren zusammenschweißen bekomme
ich einen motion detektor das sind alles
sehr coole items mit ihr nicht coole
sachen machen kann man zwar hole ich mir
dafür jetzt auch noch mal eben hier
einen wassereimer weil ich das für die
nächste sache brauche und zwar habe ich
hier wieder so ein paar notizen gemacht
aber ich mache mir immer notizen für
command und jeder denkt sich diese serie
oder stellte außen vor bleibe ich saß
ist wieder eine stunde daran an den
ganzen schick hier überall
vater alle notizen gemacht zu den ganzen
sachen also von wegen hier der ddr hat
da keine arbeit mit hier hier hier keine
arbeit jedenfalls dieser motto perlen
das was der name schon sagt nicht dass
hinsetze drückt des mobs weg das heißt
ich will schon diese spinne will
irgendwie dorthin kommen allerdings wird
sie die ganze zeit irgendwie
zurückgedrängt von diesem teil des sehen
wir auch wenn ich da beispielsweise
friedliche mops umsätze kommt jetzt
beispielsweise eine kuh anstarrte
mitgeteilt quasi einfach weggedrückt in
alle richtungen das ist mit allen sachen
so außer wenn ich dort als sind schmeiße
die werden nicht weggedrückt schilder
werden nicht weggedrückt paintings und
am nahen ostens ich weiß nicht genommen
paar sachen werden auf jeden fall nicht
weggedrückt und ich ganz einfach kaputt
machen indem ich hier ganz easy das ding
einfach so ein bisschen drauf hallo ich
gebe an den gamern 0 dann müsste ich das
nämlich eigentlich okay eigentlich
müsste ich das hier sie abbauen können
aber irgendwie funktioniert nicht an als
nächstes item haben wir hier die eisbox
und zwar wenn ich die hier einfach mal
hinsetzen seht ihr schon bekomme ich
hier so einen komischen kanister und
dort packe ich erst mal oben drei unten
drei oben drei eisengitter rein und wenn
ich jetzt in die mitte einen wassereimer
rein stelle müssen wir jetzt in kleinen
moment warten und dann bekommen wir
jeden moment als der eisblock raus und
den einmal wieder zurück und wenn ich
jetzt den als blog ganz normalen lasse
bekomme ich auch in kurzer zeit später
aus dem normalen eisblock der dort drin
ist ein packeis und das ist quasi sonne
ja die eisbox das ist sowieso ein
kühlfach im kühlschrank meerwasser
reinstellen wird irgendwann zu
gefrorenem wasser dementsprechend zu eis
das ist die eisbox sondern kommen jetzt
schon zum smog detektor der smog
detektor ist eine sache die wie der name
schon sagt kann halt auch irgendwie
identifizieren dass der rauch ist und
den kann ich nur unterhalb von block
gesetz das heißt wenn ich den hier
irgendwo hinsetzen möchte das wirklich
der der fällt dann immer wieder runter
nicht bekommen den neu das heißt ich
muss die dort oben dran setzen und wenn
ich mir jetzt zb ein feuerzeug nehmer
und das irgendwie sage ich mal hier
hinten anzünde dann passiert nichts
allerdings wenn ich das feuer hier vorne
anzündet
wimmelt dieses teil so jetzt auch zu
bimmeln und es ist quasi ganz neues kann
man sich ins gebäude stellen eine decke
packen und wenn es irgendwo anfängt zu
brennen dann kommt dieses ding und
löscht es zwar nicht aber es sagt euch
auf jeden fall dass es brennt und dann
haben wir noch die motion detektor zwar
wenig den hinstelle seht ihr schon okay
das ging dreht sich und da denkt man
beim zoll das was ich dieses ding jetzt
dreht da kann ich mir nämlich
beispielsweise hier noch eine redstone
lampe beispielsweise hinnehmen und ein
ressort anschließend geht die an
allerdings wenn ich mich außerhalb von
zehn blöcken befinde
dann geht das ganze nicht mehr und wenn
ich jetzt wieder in den zehn blöcke
radius drumrum reinke seht ihr schon
wird es die ganze ding hier wieder
aktiviert also das hier funktioniert auf
zehn blöcken entfernung und dieser
motion detektor den ich hier vorne
irgendwo gebaut hatte wo habe ich den
denn gebaut wo habe ich ihnen eingebaut
in motion detektor den feiere detektor
meine ich natürlich irgendwo hört ja dem
fall detektor gebaut der reagiert auf 16
blöcke entfernung und dieses ding hier
vorne auf 10 blöcke entfernungen und
dann würde ich sagen war das war schon
manchmal zweimal damit gemeint ein roman
nummer 3 befindet sich nämlich in einer
komplett anderen welt also die welt wird
jetzt ein bisschen anders aus und wir
sehen schon das ist keine normale kein
normaler command den ich ja ein gebe
weil ihr schon sehen ich habe keinen
command noch irgendwohin gesetzt sondern
es ist ich habe ein haar in der tastatur
das ist hier der übeltäter du kommst
erstmal hier fokussiert den scheiß mal
das wort zugesendet von bzw kreiert von
slime also geschnittene limette
irgendwie so und wir können hier einfach
eingreifen dann bekommen wir hier die
pri data sachen und das ist jetzt eine
sache das ist so ein bisschen camouflage
mäßig das heißt ach die habe ich sogar
schon an das ist natürlich ein als wenn
ich hier mit beispielsweise jetzt hier
auf gras laufen seht ihr schon passen
sich dem gras an das heißt mein aussehen
ist so bräunlich grün blabla aber wenn
ich mich jetzt von irgendwelche anderen
blöcke stelle oder beispielsweise auf
den sand blog verfärbt sich diese sachen
in farbe des sandes wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal komplett in den sand
reingehe seht ihr auch schon gleich das
auch mein oberteil gleich sandfarben
sein wird ich weiß nicht woran es liegt
dass es immer noch grünes allerdings
versichert quasi nahezu in stent in
sachen die nicht drin stehen wenn ich
jetzt beispielsweise mich auch einfach
mal in zuckerrohr stelle werde ich
direkt grün wenn ich dann allerdings
wieder in den sand gefärbt sich das
ganze wieder so ein bisschen gelblicher
das ist quasi mein mann kann man kann
sich den blöcken anpassen in der
umgebung in der
ist das heißt wenn ich auch
beispielsweise man hier nach unten gehe
bin ich halt mehr greulich bräunlich
weil ich vor den sachen stehe ich wieder
wieder auf den sand bin ich dann
allerdings wie das ein bisschen heller
angezogen gehe ich wieder in das
zuckerrohr bin ich dann wieder ein
bisschen grüner ich denke ihr wisst was
ich versuche zu sagen also wenn ich
jetzt wieder auf dem gras wenn wir nicht
dementsprechend wieder so grünlich
allerdings beim ob's funktioniert ganze
nicht das heißt ich kann mich nicht eine
schweineherde stellen und werde
dementsprechend auch pink dass wir auf
jeden fall noch die höhe wenn das noch
klappen würde wenn ich allerdings ins
wasser gehen müsste ich auch blau werden
ja genau wenn ich im wasser bin bin ich
glaube wenn ich beispielsweise hier
wieder auf das grüne gehe bin ich dann
grün wenn ich mich vor allem beim stelle
werde ich so ein bisschen bräunlicher
und mit viel fantasie kann man mich gar
nicht mehr erkennen dieser command wurde
zugesendet von slime habe ich auch schon
gesagt und es funktioniert einfach
perfekt also nahezu instant werde ich
wenn ich hier bin ist das grau wenn ich
hier hinten hin laufe bin ich wieder
gelblich wenn ich dann wieder rein
theoretisch auf das gras laufen würde
mich vom baum stellen würde werde ich
wieder so braun
mega mega cool ist mega hilfreich wegen
welche zweifel games sachen dann müsste
man sich halt nur noch irgendwie so
einen passenden skin dementsprechend an
anziehen sind ich richtig cool gemacht
und was als das aller kurz ist das ganze
funktioniert noch mit liquiden sachen
das heißt wenn ich mich vorstelle bin
ich brenne geht ihr schon dass ich
komplett rot werden das ist so schön
davon muss ich erst mal ein screenshot
machen also richtig cool auf jeden fall
ist ruckelte grad die ganze hat das habe
ich immer gerade bei dieser welt nur hab
vorhin hat es nicht geruckelt also ihnen
liegt an der welt ich weiß nicht ihr
findet den download link zu der welt
diesmal dann in der beschreibung war ein
command ist ja nicht wirklich drin
dieser command des extrem lange ich
glaube 27 millionen zeichen oder so und
es ruckelt müssen deswegen beende ich
jetzt auch einfach die folge wenn es
euch gefallen hat dass ich mir hier so
viel arbeit gebe und was ich dann will
ich mich unglaublich tolle bei den
bewertungen freund schaffen irgendwie
5000 likes es wird richtig heiß und wenn
ihr commands kennt die ich auf jeden
fall mal vorstellen soll dann einfach in
die beschreibung schreiben hey schau dir
mal den command von youtube user
blablabla an oder der command heißt so
und so und da kann man das und das
machen weil daran bestimme ich immer
also nur aus den kommentare unter den
commands welchen command sich in und
tschüss